let's talk more about the Woodward book
and the president's comments senior
political analyst Brit Hume is here with
some thoughts Keating and Brit I brought
so obviously the president pushing back
hard we've seen statements from a number
of administration officials yet Woodward
sticking by his guns saying he
interviewed more than 100 people and he
has transcripts I don't doubt that he
interviewed more than 100 people I don't
doubt that he has transcripts the
problem is of course has always been
true with Bob's books going back you
know decades and he's written a lot of
them and they and many of them have
created sensations similar to the one
this is creating is that he doesn't
disclose his sources he doesn't annotate
his books he doesn't give you a sense of
who the people are to whom he spoke and
you know that's a permissible form of
journalism but there was a time Brett
not too very long ago when I was an
investigative reporter and we used to
talk about you want your stories to be
exclusive but you don't want to remain
exclusive in other words you want them
to come out be verified to be to be
shown to be correct a tremendous amount
of what Bob wood reports is never
verified it doesn't mean it's disproven
it doesn't mean it's false it may you
know much of it may be true I'm sure it
is but it leaves us in a poor position
to evaluate the work in other words if
something is said to have occurred
during a meeting and you know you got
people coming out and saying you know he
I never said the things he claimed well
somebody must have told Bob Woodward
they did but who was that and who else
is in the meeting and what do they
remember what we don't we're not able to
do that kind of checking to verify the
claims that are in these books some in
the media say the anonymous letter to or
op-eds in the New York Times other
reporting seems to show a trend in this
general direction of the
characterization of this White House I
completely agree with that
I think look the idea that this is a
volatile president with a times volcanic
temper who was self-absorbed and
and harshly critical of people who cross
him in some way I think that's all
solidly and well that's oddly
established and well-known what I would
like to see from the people who are
seizing on these accounts of chaotic
decision-making and the president going
off in all directions is a connection
between these these outbursts from the
president and real policies and actions
on his part that match their claims
about how reckless he is so far I
haven't seen that now you could say well
look at this episode with North Korea
he's done something nobody ever did but
that's not outside the mainstream of a
policy action it's a policy choice it
may not work out or it may work out but
it campaigned on trade right it's doing
what he's doing what he campaigned on on
trade he's he's reaching out to some of
these foreign leaders in ways that
people may find disagreeable and may not
work out but they're not crazy all right
Brett as always thanks few better